Russian terror must lose everywhere in
everything on the battlefield and in the fact that it did not
leave a single hole in our country so that
we can restore everything and thereby prove that
Freedom is stronger, we also coordinate our
actions to strengthen sanctions against Russia, and
I also called on Denmark to join
our efforts  on the protection of sports
structures and the international alpine
movement from being discredited due to the efforts of
individual representatives of the sports
bureaucracy to admit Russian
athletes to the international
efforts of the International Olympic
Committee to return Russian
athletes to competitions and the Olympic
Games, this is an attempt to tell the whole world
that terror can be something acceptable, that it is
possible to turn a blind eye to  what Russia
is doing with Kherson with Kharkiv with Bakhmut
with Ovidivka today in a letter to Mr.
President Macron on this very
subject and in continuation of our
conversation with him that took place on January 24,
preparing for the Paris Olympics, we
must be sure that Russia
will not be able to use it or  any
other international sports event to
promote aggression or their state
chauvinism
in the first half of the 20th century in Europe,
too many mistakes were made that
led to very terrible tragedies. There was
also a serious Olympic mistake.
The Olympic movement and terrorist states
should definitely not intersect